the introduction scared me how so I mean
you said he wrote lady in the bathroom
and a lot of people don't know that
story so that's kind of an awkward
situation it's very simple I I'm working
with Kenny Rogers
I mean come on okay
this is back in the day
and so Kenny calls and says I want you
to write a song for me and of course I
wrote lady
and thinking he said write two songs so
I wrote one song called going back to
Alabama where we get halfway through
that song he says
I don't want to sing that song I think I
want to do um lady first
now what he didn't know was I only wrote
I only had written the first verse of
lady
so I said excuse me for a minute let me
uh go to the bathroom
[Music]
I'm sitting in the stall
writing the second verse to lady so wait
you can literally be like I'll be right
back
go and write this hit Juggernaut classic
yeah and I'll be back with you in five
minutes yeah but let me just explain
something to you you will do some
amazing things when you're scared to
death yes and so the idea of telling Mr
Rogers
I don't have the second verse was not
going to happen in my lifetime I
I
think because this is the first
interview I've ever had where the the
host is on the their knees interviewing
me this is this is very good that's how
I roll it is very amazing funny
sometimes I'm just like why do I do I
know I'm like oh my God you're the first
person who's doing it to me yeah no that
would be scary but okay so this must
have been a scary moment when you told
your parents okay I'm gonna go into the
Commodores
and I'm not going to go to college I'm
going to take this risk were you scared
how did you take that leap of faith okay
so I'm gonna give you the real story
behind that pay attention everybody this
is good it was not that I'm not going to
school I am in school I am in my senior
year
of Tuskegee University I called my dad
on the phone and I said
uh we're going on the Jackson 5 tour
with the opening act for the Jackson 5.
and my dad looked at me and I can't say
the words that he said to me on because
he's a very educated man but he he
really got nasty but no but me but you
know it was one of those things where
I believed in it so much and I think he
saw
that I believed in it
and instead of him giving me the full
Wrath of what he thought he just gave me
his little outside Skirmish which scared
me to death but the greatest thrill was
four years later
I brought him a check
and now eight years like 10 years later
excuse me from that moment
I'm now doing an interview with Barbara
Walters
and here's my father speaking to Bob
Walters it is the job of every parent to
stand firmly behind the child
and so I realized at that point you can
pay your parents off if you get really
great at this you know
[Music]
you know what I mean I mean I mean that
yes he scared me to death but he made me
put a focus on it if I don't go for my
dream now when
so I had to take that chance all right
so American Idol what season is this for
you
well Katy Perry Luke Bryan Ryan Seacrest
and all I can say to you is on American
Idol I don't know what the heck they're
gonna do
and it's not scripted that's everyone
thinks that we're making this stuff up
or somebody's writing it for us and so
every day it's a it's a step off the
edge of the Cliff of faith I mean it's
just such a good shot I thought I
thought I was going to what am I going
to do what am I going to do to teach
these kids and then I realize no no you
get on the show
and they're teaching us because you
learn something you when you see us in
tears on the show for example you know
it's not because we're sitting there
emotionally involved in their careers no
we're sitting there as parents
for example you'll ask a very simple
question tell us about your growing up
tell us about your family life and the
lady will say
we're homeless
now that has nothing to do with singing
that has to do with real life so when
you see us sitting there the first thing
we say is please God be able to sing
because the last thing I want to do is
send you away yes and most of the time
we know they can't but what we do now is
when's the last time they left any parts
of that town they were in never
so we'll say things like
you know what
we're going to send you to Hollywood
now
are they going to win the whole event
probably not
but just leaving that town for a brief
moment and meeting some new friends
could change their lives forever
think about that
[Music]